tony bennett and his family are going
public with his four-year battle with
alzheimer's disease we are very blessed
that tony was diagnosed late in life and
we could adjust
on stage he still could remember and do
every song that was never a problem
um and he still could
probably do it to this day if it hadn't
been for covid the 94 year old musician
opened up about his diagnosis in a
profile for aarp magazine on monday
revealing that he was first diagnosed in
2016.
according to the mayo clinic alzheimer's
disease is defined as a progressive
neurological disorder that causes the
brain to shrink
atrophy and brain cells to die
alzheimer's disease is the most common
cause of dementia
a continuous decline in thinking
behavioral and social skills that affect
a person's ability to function
independently
tony's doctor who diagnosed him in 2016
shared that he has cognitive issues but
multiple
other areas of his brain are still
resilient and functioning well
he is doing so many things at 94 that
many people without dementia cannot do
he really is the symbol of hope for
someone with a cognitive disorder
early on we didn't say anything because
tony could still perform and no one knew
the fact that now we are letting people
know
that tony has this is a huge relief a
weight off my shoulders in many ways
there's a lot of changes it's a lot of
sad moments but there's still a
tremendous amount of joy
that can be had and so i think i think
tony can still serve as an inspiration
to people
that uh if you love what you do whatever
it is that you do
keep doing it you don't have to hide
away tony's wife
susan also opened up about the grammy
winner's health
and revealed that his longtime
collaborator lady gaga has been
aware of his diagnosis for years
she has been lovely um you know in
return and is not
phased by performing with him knowing
that he has alzheimer's
she can just adapt and
and they're still able to really
have a lot of fun on stage and in the
recording studio
gaga also supported the family's
decision to go public
tony's son danny explained quote i
wanted to check with her to make sure
she was cool
because she watches his back all the
time she was like
absolutely it's just another gift that
he can give to the world
he always likes to say he's in the
business of making people feel good
and so he never wanted the audience to
know if he had a problem but obviously
you know as long you know as things have
progressed
it's it becomes more and more obvious
when you interact with tony that there's
something up
and so it just seemed like now was the
right time
and on monday susan sat down with cbs
this morning and said it's an honor to
be her husband's caregiver
there is nothing that gives me really
greater joy or greater pride
that i'm able to be with him and take
care of him when people say what do you
do i say i take care of a national
[Music]
treasure